[Music]
we all know kinder eggs or bands from
the US as they are a choking hazard but
do you know that Americans consume
plenty of products you'd never be able
to get in the US because they include
illegal and hazardous chemicals just
wait until you see what kind of harmful
products are actually FDA approved if
you're new here hit that subscribe
button to never miss another video and
don't forget to give us a big thumbs up
let's explore 10 foods banned in other
countries artificial dyes the FDA has a
weird relationship with artificial dyes
that help slightly less attractive food
look more appealing to eat even though
it has been reported that these diets
cause hyperactivity and are associated
with allergy and cancer risks the FDA
still approves this food in the US but
did you know the EU doesn't share the
same sentiments companies like M&M have
to remove food dye from their candy if
they want to sell it in the European
countries and it's not just candy food
dyes like yellow 5 and yellow 6 both of
which are known to produce bright yellow
colors have been removed from Kraft
orange macaroni and cheese dinner so
while the u.s. still uses these food
dyes in their food they have to be
removed and replaced with the natural
dyes when imported to Europe these diets
can be found in anything from bright
candy breakfast cereals to gelatins Ertz
and other colorful drinks but why is the
EU banning a product that's still
commonly used in the US the actual
consumption of food dyes has increased
by 500% in the past 50 years and brought
plenty of health related consequences
the studies of these dyes came back to
have shown links to types of cancers and
behavioral problems and children similar
bands have also been considered in the
US but as of 2017 all measures have been
rejected and food dye is still largely
used salmon more importantly farm-raised
salmon salmon is often associated with
healthy food as it's high in omega-3
fatty acid which comes with plenty of
health benefits and is an essential
element that supports well-being you've
probably heard that salmon also includes
elements that are also known to decrease
levels of depression and increase
neurological functions and babies but
unless you catch the salmon yourself or
know exactly where it came from you
might be consuming a food type that's
actually illegal farm-raised salmon is
banned in Australia and New Zealand and
good reason farm raised animals
including salmon are fed a completely
different diet than salmon you might
find in the wild these fish are pumped
with antibiotics and other unnatural
substances that raise its calories and
remove the natural and healthy elements
you would otherwise get in wild salmon
they have exponentially high levels of
pops4 sistent organic pollutants which
are toxic chemicals that negatively
affect a person's health and even the
environment pops4 the increasing risk of
stroke and women while Australia and New
Zealand did enforce this ban you can
pretty much get farm-raised salmon
everywhere else Scotland for instance
has reported a huge environmental
problem with farm raised salmon that are
kept in a cage and are subject to sea
lice these lice only negatively
contribute to the overall health of the
salmon and the problem seems to be only
getting worse GMO foods GMO an acronym
for genetically modified foods have had
a long history of health hazards and
other questionable effects that might
make a negative impact on human health
in 2015 more than half of Europe and GMO
foods also known as genetically modified
foods
this means GMO is not available in 28
European countries including Germany and
France environmental groups have
previously already highlighted the
negative effects of genetically modified
foods which include increased food
allergies toxicity and even decreased
nutritional value genetically modified
foods are mainly used in agriculture and
they're there to preserve the crops in
case of bad weather or any other
circumstances that would result in bad
produce in order to keep the food
growing at the same rate and always with
the same results farmers grow their
fruits and vegetables with additives
high risk GMO foods can include fruits
any type of animal products and many
vegetables although they're still
largely available in the US and many
other countries around the world they
are banned in most of Europe one of the
most popular and widely used GMO items
across the u.s. is corn the product is
used to produce many ingredients that
are used in various foods and drinks but
it all originates from the same
genetically modified crops that can have
severe negative effects on human health
rice crispies did you know that rice
crispies or any other cereals can't be
sold with the same original ingredients
in UK
Australia New Zealand Japan and even
some European countries we're sure
you've seen them on the shelves in some
of those countries but their ingredient
lists had to be adjusted and the
companies had to remove the
preservatives known as BHT and BHA both
are banned in those countries although
they're still largely used elsewhere BHT
and BHA preservatives are used to
prevent oils and foods from oxidizing
which allows you to enjoy the taste of
chips cookies and many other products
that would otherwise require a
preservative for their oils these two
chemicals can actually be found in a
large list of products that are mostly
consumed by children think breakfast
cereals cookies and sometimes even
frozen food their use has been labeled
as controversial
after several conducted studies it's
been reported that even a low use of DHA
can be toxic to cells and its
development studies have also identified
a risk of cancer and liver enlargement
however it seems like the effects
largely depend on each human as some
report showed positive results when
testing the levels of DHA regular
consumption can result in rapid health
and unpredicted behavior changes in
humans because the preservatives were
such a mystery they were banned in the
previously mentioned countries that now
use safer alternatives Tyson chicken
you've probably guessed by now that the
majority of food you consume on a
regular basis is probably banned in
other countries we bet it can be quite
scary discovering that your favorite
cereal or even your favorite type of
meat contain chemicals that can be
dangerous to your health along with
several other American food companies
Tyson Foods the company behind the
popular Tyson chicken is also on the
list of banned items Europe Russia
Norway and even Australia banned the
import of Tyson chicken Sanderson
chicken and similar companies after FDA
approved they have tested positive for
an antibiotic remedy that is not
approved in the poultry production
Sanderson farms also produced positive
results for residues of steroid hormones
and anti-inflammatory drugs which
include ketamine Tyson Foods were caught
injecting chickens with Jinta myosin a
drug that can cause permanent hearing
damage to humans many of the poultry
grown in the US contains several
unlabeled drugs that can actually
contribute the human weight gain and
eliminate most health benefits we'd
normally get from eating chicken after
public outcry Tyson Foods announced they
will phase out the antibiotics in their
chicken
by 2017 and their current statement says
that the company completely stopped
using antibiotics by September 2017
while they claim their poultry now only
uses fda-approved antibiotics Tyson
chicken is still banned from many
European countries and other places
including Russia Australia and Canada
Brad with potassium bromate whenever we
hear the word potassium we immediately
think of it as something healthy
potassium found in bananas and coconut
water can have a very positive effect on
human health but that's not the case for
potassium bromide this additive can be
found in most commercial bread types and
other baked goods
it keeps the dough more elastic and more
presentable but if there's one thing
we're learning today is that just
because something looks more attractive
on the outside it doesn't mean it's good
for you on the inside that's exactly why
commercial bread with potassium bromide
is largely banned in Canada China and
the EU
although potassium bromide has been
labeled as largely safe it can be
completely toxic to humans when consumed
it can cause headaches skin rashes and
several digestive issues India has also
banned the additive after studies
discovered the chemical is also
responsible for causing cancer it's been
reported that the mysterious additive
can be found in 84% of 38 commonly
available bread brands for the exact
same reason Center for science and
environment India proposed a banned on
potassium iodide a similar agent that's
usually used as a flour treatment in
bread both chemicals have been reported
to be harmful for human health and are
associated with cancer as well as
thyroid related issues are you consuming
bread with any of these ingredients on
the list foods with fat substitutes have
you ever heard of olestra it's a fat
substitute made to make snacks like
fat-free potato chips appear much
healthier than they actually are sounds
ideal right what could possibly go wrong
when you consume something that's been
labeled as fat-free well it turns out
that this zero calorie fat substitute
comes with many side effects that will
still negatively affect your health
seems a bit counterproductive doesn't it
this greedy chemical was approved back
in January 1996 but since then it has
caused plenty of harmful effects while
it removed unwanted fat from foods it
did prevent the body from absorbing
essential vitamins needed for human
health some of the side effects of
consuming olestra included
gasps and loose bowels you can still
find olestra and American products but
this fat substitute has been banned from
Canada and Europe so if you ever wonder
why your zero calorie chips are giving
you cramps and disturbing your bowel
movements it could just be that it's
because of a less dry the attitude is
legal and FDA even removed the olestra
label in 2003 after conducting that
stomach troubling effects are very mild
and in most cases extremely rare even so
Europe and Canada are still keeping the
additive away from their fat-free
products we'll let you be the judge of
this one sports drinks with video sports
drinks are known to be healthy right
they come with added vitamins added
protein and other elements that boost
your health and performance but in the
u.s. henderson of sports drinks can
contain an additive called b vo also
known as brominated vegetable oil this
corn or soybean oil is mixed with the
toxic element of bromine which has been
largely banned in Japan and Europe you
can find it in drinks like Mountain Dew
Fanta orange and Gatorade thirst
quencher orange B Bo acts as an
emulsifier which prevents the flavoring
and the attractive color from separating
from the drink and floating to the
surface we're pretty sure it wouldn't
make the drink look as appealing while
the FDA limits the amount of B vo to 15
parts per million beverages the
emulsifier has been completely banned in
Europe and Japan bromine the same
chemical which can be found in bread can
also be found in many sports drinks
absorbing bromine replaces your body's
needs for iodine which can cause a
deficiency and an increased risk of
breast cancer thyroid glands and ovary
and prostate cancers bromine has also
been found to accumulate in the central
nervous system and breast milk it's been
known to cause a number of health
problems since 1971 but somehow the
strange additive is still largely used
in many u.s. drinks
American milk Europe also has a strange
relationship with American milk although
it makes sense to not import milk from
the US due to the product shelf-life
there's another reason why you might
never see American milk products on
European shelves American milk products
contain rb/gh a growth hormone which is
injected in dairy cows to increase milk
production this hormone has been
reportedly linked to cancer
and increased levels of thyroid hormone
enzyme rb/gh is also responsible for an
increased in long-chain fatty acid
levels which pose several cardiovascular
risks our bgh has also been associated
with excess levels of natural
insulin-like growth factor-1 which has
been reported to increase breast cancer
colon cancer and prostate cancer risks
due to these concerns the consumption of
American milk has been banned in many
countries including Norway Switzerland
Japan New Zealand Australia and 29
European nations that opted out for a
safer alternative the FDA has been
criticised for not publishing studies
that clearly show the dangers of using
rb/gh and milk and continues to state
that there is no significant difference
between rb/gh and non rb/gh milk however
it has been reported that cows exposed
to rb/gh often shows stress and
infections to their other which means
they also have to be infused by
antibiotics many of which are illegal in
the US what do you think should rb/gh be
banned in the u.s. meat with arsenic and
last but not least Europe has also
banned a substance that's largely used
in plenty of American poultry if you're
still watching you've probably
discovered that the US culture isn't
exactly raised to be the healthiest
option for humans and you can have many
negative effects on human health but
while you're on the lookout for
chemicals we mentioned earlier you
should also keep in mind a substance
known as arsenic while organic arsenic
is an approved drug and the less toxic
type it can transform into inorganic
arsenic which can be found in elevated
levels of supermarkets stored chicken
arsenic is largely used to burst blood
vessels and make the chicken look pink
and plump this can have negative effects
on the soil which as a result affects
the entire environment but of course
long-term exposure can increase cancer
risks and cause chromosome damage so how
come you can still find arsenic in the
u.s. poultry unfortunately it's because
FDA thinks it's perfectly fine
while this drug field meat is banned in
Europe it's still largely available in
the US
as the FDA declared the products are
safe because of organic arsenic since
then the statement has been questioned
by scientific reports which have found
plenty of traces of inorganic arsenic
are actually associated with cancer
risks we've mentioned earlier so next
time you buy any kind of poultry make
sure you avoid any toxic substances you
might not even know you're consuming and
that's it for our video for more videos
like this one check out 10 foods you'll
never buy again after knowing how they
are made
see you next time
[Music]